[Music]
okay Stone falls is amazing man on the
love is their bull neck I'm concerned
you can tell the difference between a
full-on a fatty the bull neck is bigger
heavy guys come on let's do this oh that
is nasty okay be careful guys I think
we're approaching the final boss where's
Tony
watch his patterns rollers off of me
everyone everything you've got it's all
of that let's go come on this is a
veteran challenge mess stay focused okay
I was just reading the craziest book I
don't know where anybody want to check
this out making myself look pretty big
blue Titan making a little money right
now I'm just borrowing from people I
have got this
I am you guys suck oh man there's like
nobody guarding this okay are you not
seeing this I'm on a giant chicken
lizard shut your mouth
good you're the destroyer Tony when
you're on you're on axe to the face
nice work Tony seriously you should pull
it like this all the time if you play
like this all the time
ah who wants to go fishing
you